jours tout le monde je m'appelle nicolas
fatwa et je suis un réalisateur de films
d'animation libanais venant d'un petit
village où il ya aucun centre
d'amusement comme un cinéma un espace de
jeu ou un théâtre
la seule chose qu'on pouvait faire pour
tuer le temps était de raconter des
histoires et moi aussi j'en raconter ses
histoires n'étaient pas tirés de mon
imagination
mais c'était plutôt les vraies aventures
des habitants de mon village et ce qui
m'intéressait dans ça ce n'était pas du
tout les actions des personnages mais
c'était plutôt les réactions des gens
qui m'écoutait et moi je faisais tout
pour capter le plus de réactions
possibles
je me souviens bien des visages choqué
des fous rires et surtout surtout des
punitions que j'ai eu à cause des
exagérations que je pouvais dire c'est
pour cela à l'âge de 8 ans j'ai voulu
investir ce don que j'avais qui est de
raconter des histoires en une forme qui
est un peu plus magique à mon sens alors
j'ai commencé à écrire des pièces de
théâtre et à les diriger
avec l'aide de mes deux petites soeurs
et de mes amis d'école ont passé des
heures et des heures à découper des
cardons multicolores pour faire les
décors et ont volé de l'atelier de mon
père des morceaux de bois et de la
peinture avec laquelle on peignait non
seulement les décors mais aussi bien sûr
sans faire attention
le sol nouveaux habits et même parfois
nos visages et le jour de la performance
ce grand jour qui était tant attendu
tous des parents étaient invités à notre
terrasse pour une à deux heures et eux
ils étaient là juste pour voir leurs
petits chouchous déployer tout leur
talent sur scène et dès le lendemain
mais ce rémois on faisait le travail
forcé pour nettoyer toute la maison et
effacer toute la peinture est allé sur
le sol c'est vrai que ces moments
étaient souvent fatigant mais ils
représentent jusqu'à aujourd'hui de très
beaux souvenirs pour moi
et tout se passait bien j'ai toujours
fait des pièces de théâtre jusqu'au jour
où des membres de la troupe ont
découvert une activité qui est beaucoup
plus amusant à faire comme les
mathématiques la physique la chimie et
toutes ces autres matières que j'ai
jamais pu comprendre d'ailleurs -
lorsque j'étais à l'école j'ai passé mon
temps à étudier les caractères de mes
professeurs au lieu de leur matière et
lorsque j'étais seul à la maison je d
imiter au lieu de faire mes devoirs et
puisque j'avais beaucoup plus de temps
livre n'étant plus metteur en scène j'ai
commencé à exposer mes oeuvres
artistiques avec celle de mon père qui
est un peintre très connu au liban alors
je m'exposais avec ses tableaux mes
tableaux des chapeaux en papier une
collection de bagues en fil de fer que
je travaillais avec mes soeurs et on a
intitulé sa collection la barque de
chance je m'en souviens que pour attirer
les gens vers notre sens on inventait
des chansons vont chercher avec nous des
peureux que mes soeurs portait juste
pour faire semblant d'être des clients
très intéressés par notre marchandise
ont commencé à parler avec une très
haute voix ou python ont crié pour faire
entendre tous les genres ou d'entourage
comment une bague de chance a pu par
exemple aider une femme très laide à se
marier ou a pu aider la pinterie exposé
juste à côté de nous à vendre toutes ses
croûtes en trois jours c'est vrai que
ces vagues n'avaient pas vraiment de
pouvoirs magiques mais il était fait
avec tout notre coeur et c'était ça qui
apportait de la chance aux gens la vie
est tellement simple vous voyez mais
avec le temps
mes amis ont grandi des gens ont changé
le monde a changé
raconter des histoires imiter des
professeurs vendre des bagues en fil de
fer ou même des chapeaux en papier n'est
plus comme avant
des gens ne rêve plus facilement ne
pleure plus facilement et ne rigole plus
facilement je m'en souviens que lorsque
j'étais jeune je croyais que ma maison
était à tout le monde
et lorsque je visitais mes amis
j'avais l'impression que j'étais
toujours dans ma maison j'ouvris leur
frigo comme si c'était le mien
j'allumais leur télévision consistait la
mienne mais aujourd'hui lorsque je le
rends visite
je n'ose plus haut vers leur frigo ni
allumer leur télévision je ne comprends
pas en quoi un frigo une télévision
pourrait faire peur et je ne comprends
pas non plus pourquoi parfois je suis
dérangé
lorsque quelqu'un ose ouvrir mon frigo
ou allumer ma télévision sans ma
permission
et c'est ainsi que j'ai commencé à
découvrir les murs qui entourent et ma
maison et celle des autres j'ai commencé
à découvrir mon visage mon corps est
celui des autres et j'ai donné des
adjectifs à ce que je voyais j'ai
remarqué que mon nez un peu long mon
ventre et un peu gros mais sert ne sont
très foncé les sourciers de mon ongle
son épée et la poitrine de sa femme elle
est très complet et depuis ces adjectifs
ont commencé à prendre la place de ce
que je voyais le long cacher le nez le
gros cachet le ventre les fonds s'est
caché les serres les épées cacher des
sourcils et la gonfle et cacher la
poitrine
juste comme un mur cache ce qu'il ya à
l'intérieur de nos maisons et parfois on
met même des couches et des décorations
sur nos murs pour les embellir et pour
arrêter les gens de va et d'imaginer ce
qu'il ya à l'intérieur
faisons une pause vous l'aurez compris
en grandissant je remarquais que les
gens autour de moi sont devenus beaucoup
moins vivant qu'avant c'est pour cela en
j'ai commencé à faire du cinéma
d'animation voulant animer ces gens
autour de moi animer ces murs et en 2015
dans le cadre académique
j'ai réalisé mon premier court métrage
intitulé le voleur de casseroles ce film
est basé sur une citation libanaise très
connu et à fort tonnage en france s est
frotté ou de l'enrichir des casseroles
on utilise cette citation pour décrire
des gens qui cherchent toujours à
impressionner les autres juste pour
recevoir un complément en revanche
et parfois on fait beaucoup de bruit
avec nos casseroles pour distraire les
gens
et pour d empêcher de nous écouter et
maintenant je vous laisse découvrir ce
film
[Musique]
je m'appelle qui je suis allée de
nos mères sur ma planète
les gens ont des casseroles blanche
attaché au corps pour rester vivants ils
doivent toujours là frottés sur la rade
de fautes et il meurt
ils ne dorment jamais de faire jamais
les yeux en est c'est parce qu'il frotte
la casserole
le complément sort lise parent à
l'oreille passe par le gie culure
ensuite les mages acquis et après
l'egypte 0 et enfin un rêve au poumon et
enfin disparaît de mon pays il a des
riches qui ne voient pas leurs
casseroles
ils ont une main artificielle qui fait
le travail mais parfois cette main
arrête de fonctionnement et 1 ne
réagissent pas il ne faut jamais
d'efforts mois moi je suis différent je
les nie casseroles ni grandes oreilles
ma maman est partie lorsque les
espionner et mon papa a sauté par la
fenêtre j'ai quitte rarement à la maison
les enfants ne veulent pas jouer avec
moi quand je m'approche plus ils s'en
foutent
il va faire de moi il croit que je suis
un voleur un voleur de castrol il croit
que je vais prendre leurs casseroles
parce que moi je n'en ai pas la nuit
fils le ciel et je me fais une promesse
un jour je trouverai un ami un ami qui
me ressemble je ne verrai plus jamais
seul il n'y avait qu'un ami je suis sûr
que si moi j'existe
il doit en exister un autre quelque part
lancement
[Musique]
e
aujourd'hui je suis en train de
travailler sur mon premier projet
professionnel
intitulée my one man 2 le 10 km est cher
ce projet qui en coproduction avec
l'allemagne vient de gagner depuis
robert bosch stiftung dans la catégorie
animation et il est aussi financé par
afaq ma grand mère habitait tout près de
chez moi
et c'est peut-être la raison principale
pour laquelle que j'ai jamais senti le
besoin de lui rendre une visite
je croyais qu'elle va toujours être là
et que j'ai énormément de temps de la
visiter plus tard mais un jour
soudainement elle n'était plus là
et ceci m'a brisé le coeur missionné en
rentrant chez elle pour la première fois
et en fouillant dans ses objets qu'elle
a baissé que j'ai remarqué que ma grand
mère n'a jamais quitté sa maison mais
par contre elle a revécu à travers tous
ces meubles qu'elle a utilisé pour
continuer à veiller sur ses enfants
veiller sur sa famille c'est l'histoire
d'une vieille femme qui en perdant ses
cinq sens se transforme en une chaise en
bois celle d'une énorme bête épineuse
qui se transforme en une douce femme de
ménage et de neuf petits enfants qui
nous visitons grand mère que très
rarement se transforme à leur tour
hancock
vous allez me demander c'est quoi le
rapport entre l'histoire de mon film et
le thème des murs et des ombres en effet
des trois transformations qui se passe
dans ce film ne sont pas le fruit du
hasard
par exemple c'est l'adjectif on sait que
ma grand-mère attribué à la peau de sa
femme de ménage qui a rendu cette
dernière épineuse est monstrueuse et ce
néant ne plus payant attention à cet
adjectif on sait que grand-mère réussi à
la fin du film de découvrir la beauté et
la douceur de rose et ses roses la femme
de ménage qui était la première à
découvrir l'importance de la chaise de
grand-mère pour beaucoup de gens en
regardant cette chaise il ne voit que du
bois du tissu un truc pour s'asseoir
mais pour moi rose et d'autres personnes
proches des deux on voit ni le bois ni
les tissus les par contre l'humain qui a
utilisé cette chaise on voit grand mère
enfin c'est vrai que nous des êtres
humains on ne pourra jamais s'empêcher
de voir les qualités et les défauts des
autres on ne pourra jamais s'empêcher de
juger ou des tribus et des adjectifs à
ce qu'on voit mais parfois ces murs qui
nous entoure ils sont en train de nous
bloquer nous nous empêcher de voir de
découvrir ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur un
mur mais peut être long petit ep fin
sales ou propres mais il ne pourra
jamais être gentil méchant tristes ou
joyeux
je me demande si un jour nous les êtres
humains on arrivera à voir dans les
autres qui nous ressemble au lieu du
long du joli du petit ou du moche on
pourra voir ces adjectifs qui sont un
peu plus humain ceux qui peuvent décrire
les uns des autres comme la joie la
tristesse la méchanceté l'orgueil comme
ça ces murs qui nous entoure ne pourront
plus jamais nous tromper sur des
apparences et deviendront des portes que
l'on peut ouvrir
merci beaucoup